how are you guys doing I hope you're
having a good time I hope Ramadan is
serving you well I hope you were doing
the Quran and the fasting and the and
also the charity and the prophet sallam
was most charitable most generous in
this month of Ramadan and before I get
started I saw a video Yeah of the you
know You' have known if you watch my
videos that we're raising money for a
Masjid and a huge mega da Center in
Norway which will become a beacon of
light for the whole of the northern kind
of European area and beautiful man they
were pring and I was very happy and glad
that our contributions could actually
facilitate that so if you want to
continue the expansions that they're
doing because they haven't finished yet
they doing lots more expansions and
stuff then click the link
below now having said that I was going
to say um I recently came across a video
whereby Jordan Peterson was speaking to
some other person about Elon Musk now
you guys would have known if you had
watched my videos before that a conduit
who has public ties with Elon Musk okay
made some threats towards me saying that
if you don't stop criticizing me this
that any other that this will happen to
you etc etc and I documented and I got I
don't know some 3 400,000 views in the
video but since then you know the
following has been said let's take a
look at this video and come back and
respond in kind so Tommy's in jail right
now as we mentioned because he published
that video to Twitter contrary to a
judge don't that's right and so it's a
contempt of court Elon Musk has came in
to help fund the legal battle oh okay
okay so that's taken care of and the
only reason I'm saying that in public is
that it was released publicly oh when
did that come out that was uh in the
last month uh okay so uh Elon Musk is
very interesting he believes in the UK
and he's frustrated and and in Germany
yeah and so it it it is in the public
domain that that happened so that's sort
of incredible and what about pressure
from from like viewers and listeners are
there someone that can be written like
they they are very the UK government in
my assessment is extremely nervous about
how to deal with Trump and Trump's they
should be buddy Elon Musk yeah now if
you guys know that i' I'm actually
taking Tommy Robinson to court I'm
taking five different people to court in
the United Kingdom just for def
information of character that's just the
UK I've got court cases across Europe
and and other places in the world but
just five in the UK and one of them is
Tommy Robinson and so here there's a
clear link there's a clear link between
Elon Musk and Tommy Robinson that clear
link comes off the back of these threats
that he's been
sending supposedly and allegedly to me
yeah of course through the conduit now
I'm saying to you that I just want to
send a message to all of you yeah I know
there's recent recently if you're
following also I've been banned like I
had been banned for 26 different
European countries and then we took them
to court Dutch government we won so
governments and billionaires are paying
attention to what we're doing here first
of all that's a testament to how strong
the Muslim Community is that a
workingclass guy from West London can um
essentially yeah get through to these
individuals and get them to act in this
triggered manner why why are they doing
that in this kind of fragile manner is
because they realize the strength for
the Muslim Community that's number one
number
two yeah you have to understand our
mindset our mindset is the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam told us our
Prophet Muhammad the last and final
Prophet that was sent to humankind told
us that if the whole world comes
together and they try to harm you
that they will not be able to harm you
except with a thing that Allah has
written for
you so you can try your best and do this
to any other but the truth of the matter
is it's all Allah's will yeah if Allah
wants to Humble me if Allah wants to
give me Victory if Allah whatever that
that is whatever he wants to do will
happen so at the end of the
day as the Quran states that you do not
will except that Allah Wills so your
will is subordinate yeah my will and
your will is subordinate is subjugated
and is secondary to the ultimate
Sovereign will of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala no matter what your name is
whether you think you've got the most
money in the world this that and the
other whether Elon Musk thinks is this
that and we I might make a review about
Tesla actually because his stocks are
plummeting and he's having a a panic
attack I might actually just go into a
Tesla car and do a review Top Gear style
yeah and I know Top Gear is another
organization that he actually I think
tried to take to court I have to double
check that because of a negative review
that he made on on a car so I might have
have to get myself into a Tesla and do a
review but that's another video for
another day I'll leave you guys to it
inshallah and don't forget to click the
link below for the the project